la guerre du feu et déclarés en auvergne
je m'explique le projet de construction
d'un parc d'attraction au coeur des
volcans d'auvergne suscite en effet une
polémique à travers ce projet initié par
le président de région valéry giscard
d'estaing
ce sont deux conceptions du tourisme qui
s'affrontent et c'est le thème ce soir
de notre enquête menée par valérie gager
et philippe jasselin autour d'un musée
au dessous du volcan une ceinture de
barbelés et des grilles hermétiquement
closes le site choisi pour l'emplacement
de vulcania le futur centre européen du
volcanisme a gardé ses allures d'anciens
dépôts militaires
mais ce terrain acheté par la région 90
bénéficie d'un environnement
exceptionnel au coeur du parc naturel
des volcans d'auvergne
il n'est qu'à quelques encablures du
sommet du puy de dôme ici à l'orée de
l'an 2000 s'élèvera peut être un grand
centre de loisirs s'élèvera ou plutôt
s'enfoncera car la maquette de
l'architecte autrichien révèle un
bâtiment aux trois quarts enterré
seule une cheminée au de 20 mètres
émergera au dessous du volcan
artificiels cinq niveaux souterrains
abriteront une série de grottes dédié à
vulcain
coulée de lave magma vibrations fumée
vulcania qui devrait coûter au bas mot
360 millions de francs veut offrir un
voyage virtuel au centre de la terre à
ses visiteurs c'est au début de 97 que
de pouvoir commencer le projet je vis
j'aimerais que nous puissions l'ouvrir
au printemps de l'an 2000 et puis au
point de vue de la symbolique ça sera
probablement le plus grandes
réalisations françaises de l'époque en
réalité une réalisation d'avant garde
beaucoup de points de vue et donc ça
donnerait une forte image de l'eau vnc
le calendrier que nous allons essayer de
tenir des censeurs intarissable d'un
projet qui est avant tout le sien valéry
giscard d'estaing y multiplie les
réunions d'information auprès des élus
auvergnats président du conseil régional
mais aussi président du parc naturel
vge met tout son poids dans la balance
pour que vulcania sorte un jour de terre
quitte à bousculer un peu l'article 15
de la charte du parc qui précise que
l'implantation d'infrastructures lourdes
est incompatible avec l'image du parc
naturel pour un projet de ce type il
fallait qu'il soit dans un milieu
volcaniques vous pourrez pas attirer des
gens c'est comme si vous vouliez faire
un musée graphique on va peut être à
l'intérieur des terres dans la visite
après les chants le fait qu'il soit dans
un environnement volcanique satie voix
contre nature l'ensemble de la chaîne
des puys les volcans c'est dans
l'élément qui paraît très important
giscard de scop c'est le surnom donné à
vulcania par ses adversaires regroupés
en comités plusieurs associations ont
déposé trois recours devant le tribunal
administratif qui ont retardé le début
des travaux
défenseurs de l'environnement ces
militants dénoncent les risques de
pollution dans une région réputée pour
ses sources
surtout ils craignent les conséquences
d'un tourisme de masse vulcania espère
en effet accueillir plus de cinq cent
mille visiteurs dès la première année
il faut savoir quand même que tous les
soirs il y aura des feux d'artifice sur
ce site il y aura la chaîne des puys
couverte de deux spots la nuit pour que
les gens puissent faire des randonnées
nocturnes dans dans ces milieux naturels
nous craignons aussi l'arrivée de l'a 89
en plein milieu du parc naturel régional
des volcans et tous ces projets auront
un impact énorme sur la nature en
retournant sur le site choisi pour
vulcania on constate avec surprise que
juste en face existe déjà amusé du
volcanisme un extraordinaire volcan à
ciel ouvert ce site privé a reçu 70
mille visiteurs l'an dernier
contrairement à vulcania il n'est
pourtant guère encouragé par les
collectivités locales
nous avons demandé un recompte bandeau
la commune de ceinture les roches noires
fusée en 96 l'on se trouve à 400 mètres
de notre site et rapallo à l'eau
courante que préféreront les touristes
du 21e siècle ce site lunaire ou rien
est factice ou le monde virtuel de
vulcania la question agite pas le plus
jeune des volcans d'auvergne qui s'est
endormi il y a eu mille ans